- [Host] Every morning,
thousands of dogs wake up not for a day of barks and naps,
but to work.
More than half a million people rely on a service dog
in their everyday lives, but these are no ordinary pups.
A dog's journey from carefree puppy to hero is a long one
filled with trials, triumphs, and setbacks.
It takes months and years to train these elite dogs
for all the rigors of service dog life,
and not all puppies that begin the process will graduate.
Follow along as a handful of puppies
go through a month of training, obstacles, and field trips
all to get just that much closer to graduation.
^There's steady Deacon, charismatic Luke,
^shy Benelli, confident Kaya, wilcard Remmy,
^and, of course, the undeniable Mr. Pip.
Do any of these puppies have the smarts and spirit
to pass service dog school?
Find out in Puppy Prep.
(inspirational music)
(birds chirping)